good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation one of the
conversations that long now is head with
itself all along when thinking long-term
is we're constantly wondering is there
something we could do this better than a
university and in some ways this series
of talks is an outgrowth of that
conversation and will universities
persist they've been around for a
thousand years and that's not bad but
you look back the first university in
the West really was the Library of
Alexandria which wasn't called the
library is called the moosian museum
museum comes from that it was a place
where thinkers accumulated and indeed
all the books of the time accumulated
and brightest people interacted with
each other and as you look around what
our current amazing alternatives to
university the Smithsonian Institution
stands out as it does all the things the
university does does education does
science does a major interaction of
conversation unlike universities it's
not in one place it's all over Hill and
gone
it's been around damn near as long as
America and so it has already been
helping Americans and everybody who
visits these places 7 million a year or
something like that
to think long term and the new head of
the Smithsonian secretary is he's called
Wayne Clough is extending that he's
extending it tonight
before we let him do that
we want to present him with the thing
and Laura welter is here to do that
you know I give talks and they come up
and they give you a Pendleton blanket or
which is the best one I ever got I think
of you a weird little momento which you
try to lose on the way to the airport we
hope this is better than that so my name
is Laura Welch and I direct there was
that a project at the long now
foundation and when the long now
foundation was first getting started and
Stewart wrote the book of the clock of
the long now he proposed that along with
the clock we should also have a library
a 10,000 year library and so alongside
the clock we've had a couple of projects
that have been our thinking about what
this library would be it may eventually
be a physical space but to now it's
mostly been a mental space and one of
that one of those projects as long bets
so a place where you can is kind of a an
accountability record over time and the
other project that we have is rosetta
and that's a collection of information
about the world's languages and that
content turns out to be a pretty good
kind of content for the long view
because languages are a product of
millennia of human cultural development
so tonight on the occasion of doctor
cloths talked to us about Smithsonian
forever we would like to present him
with our a new a new version of the
rosetta disk which you can see here and
you can see up on our screen there
and so this dr. Clough is an archive of
the world's languages it has on it
microscopically etched which you'll have
to read with the microscope documents on
over 1500 human languages and there's
13,000 pages on that disk so from our
10,000 year archive to your forever
archive on behalf of the loan a
foundation
thank you very much Thank You Stuart
and Laura thank you very much for that
wonderful and thoughtful presentation to
the Smithsonian of course they won't let
me have it I don't get to touch anything
at the Smithsonian as my archivist I
always tell me don't touch that
so you have to be very careful but it
will become part of the Smithsonian
archives and that's an important part of
it and at some point in my remarks I
will speak to this matter of languages
which is really part of the protection
if you will of our culture and the
Smithsonian is involved in all of these
things well I've had the wonderful
experience to be involved in with
institutions here in the Bay Area in my
past because I went to Berkeley for my
doctorate back in the wild and wooly 60s
and alright and then after a small stint
back at Duke University I taught at
Stanford for about a decade and it was
wonderful time here in the Bay Area and
have many friends here and the
Smithsonian has many friends who's
helped support us in our mission as well
and we're very grateful to all of them
so if you live as long as I have and
you've been as many places that I have
sometimes things circle around on
themselves and it turned out at the
Smithsonian one of the exciting things I
got to do was to accept a gift from
Christo and jean-claude of the remnants
of the running fence project and one of
the young archivist at the Smithsonian
American Art Museum asked me are you old
enough to have been there when the
running fence project was there and of
course I had to say yes I was old enough
to have been there in fact I was there
before it was there but it was a
wonderful experience to meet Christo and
John Claude and I had the great obvious
another experience in see their gates
project in what in New York City which
are marvelous things so these are great
experiences you get to have
as Secretary of the Smithsonian and in
this process of choosing objects and
bringing them into the Smithsonian and
it really relates to the topic we're
going to talk about tonight the
Smithsonian like any cultural and/or
educational institution today is facing
budget challenges and difficult choices
that we have to make because none of us
are immune from these things at the same
time we have remarkable opportunities
that I will describe to you tonight and
so we have to make choices so in the
process of getting our arms around where
we are going as an institution we've
been doing some heavy-duty thinking
strategic planning if you will and we've
been able to fortunately have the
services of double business networks and
Peter Schwartz whose work with us on
scenario based planning and as a member
of the long now foundation and Peter
arranged for me to meet with the long
now board and have one of our scenario
based discussions about the future and
we began thinking about time and what
time really meant and at the Smithsonian
how that plays out and that really
that's where this talk come from I think
and it set me to thinking about time and
the Smithsonian and I want to share some
of those thoughts with you because it's
a very important issue for us so we are
at that point we've where you have to
make important decisions one of the
other groups that Peter arranged for me
to meet with was a group of young
Millennials here in California these are
people who are shall we say younger than
me probably 20 22 23 you know born in
about 1989 1990 and their memory of
things is quite different than my memory
of things and so it was interesting in
that discussion very lively discussion
and at one point I asked the group what
would you like the Smithsonian to do for
you and I explained to them you own the
Smithsonian it's publicly owned you own
it and you own our hundred and thirty
seven million objects that are in our
collection but you've probably never
seen them and one young woman looked at
me and she said surprise me surprise me
so she wanted to be surprised and well
you could say in on one sense if you
wanted to be a little cynical well this
is just that new
generation young generation always
looking for something new and wanting to
be surprised but I think it was a deeper
sentiment that she had because we know
really when you look at creativity
creativity and surprise are two sides of
the same coin there's no such thing as
creativity without surprise one of the
interesting things if you google
surprise and creativity what it takes
you to is a page on robotics as it turns
out as astute as robots can be about
mechanical tasks they cannot be
surprised yet there are people who are
working on that but surprise is an
important part of what humans do and so
what I want to talk about tonight is
surprise in the sense of the Smithsonian
so in the timeframe of what we might say
is now I'm hoping that we will also be
able to talk about what we would call
the long now and what the long now
foundation brings to us and what the
Smithsonian does in the same sense when
I speak to you night I'm really gonna
divide this up into three parts the
first part could be now because I want
to explain a little bit about what the
Smithsonian does I've found even myself
when I went there I didn't understand
the Smithsonian and I think that's
important the second part could be
called the long now of the past and
because the Smithsonian deals a lot with
history and historical objects and
objects actually that go back fairly far
into time and that reflects on what we
will know about the future when we study
history of course and the third element
of the talk will be the long now of the
future because it really is all about
the future learning about the past is
actually all about the future tell you a
little bit about the Smithsonian and let
me get this going here so those are the
three things I just mentioned the
Smithsonian owes its existence to a
British scientist a chemist named James
Smithson who never set foot in this
country but bequeathed this estate to
the United States and a very broad
mandate saying for the establishment of
an institution called a Smithsonian
Institution that would increase and
diffuse knowledge and it was physically
created by an act of Congress in 1846 it
took a while ten years after the request
took Congress ten years to figure out
what way
do with the money but it was in fact to
create the Smithsonian Institution
so 163 years later we are still focused
on these dual missions of research and
education and I think our education
mission is probably more obvious of the
two to most people most people in fact
see us through the lenses of our 19
museums where the largest museum complex
in the world and we also operate the
National Zoo and that as a historical
basis in it and in fact some 27 million
visits are made to the Smithsonian we
will get 7 million visits at any one of
our museums that's a huge number of
people coming to see us every day of the
year but one Christmas we're open all
the time many others subscribe to
Smithsonian's magazine and I'd encourage
you to do that because it helps us with
the advertising and we need a little
money but it helps you understand a
little bit more about the Smithsonian we
have multiple research centers we have
20 libraries and we work in 88 different
countries and now with digital access we
have an even greater reach teachers and
students across the United States and
around the world our beginning to know
us because of something called the
Encyclopedia of life which is a project
from our Museum of Natural History which
is going to develop a webpage for every
species that we know that exists on
earth and that's a remarkable device and
our interactive seminars have just begun
we just did one about Lincoln we simply
didn't advertise it because we wanted to
see if it worked
4200 people joined in because they could
see all of our exhibits on Lincoln and
participate in interact with the
curators it attracted people from all 50
states and then the surprise because we
never thought we would see it 70
countries participated we didn't
advertise it at all and yet people from
70 countries are interested in Abraham
Lincoln then we thought that was a good
thing we'll do another one the next one
is in September primarily directed at
the K through 12 environment it will be
on global warming which the Smithsonian
has a great deal to say about we're also
working in social media activities for
example you can play online games with
the Smithsonian American Art Museum
called ghost of a chance which is a
basica scavenger
that gets kids interest young people
interested in art and so we are active
now in the digital world and you'll see
more of that to come so all of these
avenues and of Education communication
point to our vast collection of things
and material objects that we've amassed
since we began collecting in 1846 now in
a very real sense the Smithsonian is a
curator to the world because we collect
objects all over the world
not just from our country we even
collect objects in outer space and I'll
talk about that a little bit later the
question is what is worth preserving
when you're collecting what is worth
preserving it's a challenging task out
of all of the material objects that make
up of our work make up our world out of
all of the information that is flashing
by us today in bits and bytes how do we
decide what to grasp and keep what's
important for the future some things are
unique in spectacular a spacesuit from
John Glenn is spectacular we would
preserve that but many things in our
collections may have been considered
rather ordinary in their day but they've
taken on significance through time so
that decision is an important one as an
example our specimens of animals we for
example how six hundred and fifty
thousand deceased birds in our
collection they're important they were
important to type species in the past to
understand something about evolution of
species but today we can extract DNA
from these species and learn even more
about what it means what the different
species manifests themselves as and so
forth we are collecting now a genetic
database as part of the barcode of life
that will help establish actually how
many species there are on planet Earth
and we can serve unexpected needs for
example when the US Airlines plane went
down over the Hudson River as you may
remember it as they say ingested birds
into the engines and had to make an
emergency landing they came to the
Smithsonian with the remains of the
birds because we identify things like
that and so up to 4500 Birds strikes per
year come to the Smithsonian because we
have the bird collection
we can actually identify the birds it
turns out these were as you've probably
read Canada geese Canada geese there
were two females we determined and one
male and in fact they were not the
hanging around New York City type of
Canada geese they were migratory why is
that important if they're hanging around
the airport you can get rhythm if
they're migrating they're migrating
folks and makes you a little nervous
when you're taking off and landing but
that's the way life is so that's a
useful use of our collection but at a
deeper level the essence we're searching
for and everything we collect and in all
the research we do is meaning meaning we
want to capture what it means to be
human and to gather a collective
statement of how our society understands
and remembers itself and then we want to
put that meaning into a larger context
of the unfolding of our species and
indeed the universe so we care much more
than just about the objects or the facts
much of our search is for meaning based
on connections and relationships
relationships these relationships
between humans and our tangible objects
in the immediate world of everyday life
over time constitute our identity and
make our culture what it is and then
their relationships between human beings
and the larger context of the planet and
the universe our search for meaning
brings history art the sciences into
relationship with each other
and the Smithsonian is unusual in that
regard that it spans all these different
areas most museums most complexes most
research complexes are focused and we
are focused but on these broad areas the
relationships between human beings us
and the objects that comprise our world
are invariably sensory it's what we see
what we hear what we taste and indeed
perhaps what we hear the Smithsonian is
getting interested in that side of the
equation what we hear because it's part
of the understanding of the object
itself for example
if we were to think about making pottery
and the object of collecting pottery in
the art that is in pottery what do we
miss we missed the process of the making
of the pottery think of a potter turning
a vessel on the wheel that's all part of
the process the creative process suppose
we could record that and that would
enhance our understanding of how that
object came into being or take Mickey
Hart the drummer for the Grateful Dead
Mickey Hart has a new interest these
days not just in music but particularly
what the cosmos might be saying to us in
the form of music well it turns out
there's a lot of music in the universe
we have many we have almost 1/6 of our
employees that the Smithsonian are
engaged in the business of astronomy or
astrophysics most of them in Cambridge
Massachusetts at the Smithsonian
Astrophysical Observatory work with
Harvard and as our astronomers will tell
me we never thought about listening we
thought about looking and seeing well
Mickey came and said what about
listening well it turns out there's a
lot to listen to you can actually still
hear the remnants of the Big Bang from
14 billion years ago the Sun sends us
sensory messages every day and so
there's a lot out there to make music
from and Mickey working with our
astronomers and our astrophysicists are
gonna make music that'll be fun that's
one of the things that makes it fun
about being at the Smithsonian these
things can happen there well I was
fortunate to be born in this country in
a small town of Douglas Georgia in the
deep south rural town and along the way
I went one too far I think along the way
I gained an appreciation for Southern
writers notably William Faulkner and I
read everything he wrote and I learned
something about the timeframe for the
long now from William Faulkner as I
thought back to the words of this young
man play chick mallison in Faulkner's
novel intruder in the dust he said
tomorrow began ten thousand years ago
the timeframe of the clock the Faulkner
we could add the words of Winston
Churchill who said the father backwards
you can look the father forward you
can see so we believe that at the
Smithsonian our long-term thinking is
based on the premise that the history of
the universe and planet earth and its
inhabitants is a relevant guide to the
future so at the Smithsonian we see
ourselves as time travelers we spend a
considerable effort looking back into
time back even further than 10,000 years
for clues that will help us understand
and perhaps anticipate what the future
will bring and tonight I'd like to
invite you to join me as we travel back
into the very long now of the
Smithsonian timeline as defined by a few
examples of how we try to understand the
past so as we begin with our little
experiment in time at in this
presentation
our scope begins quite close at hand and
with ourselves as Americans members of a
country call the United States and then
we're going to broaden it out as members
of the universe so let's think a little
bit about 300 years of US history 300
years that's all we've been around it
represents our efforts to try to capture
when we talk about this time period
capturing the identity of the American
experience the experience in this
country through our history and culture
artifacts are an important way to
connect people with their heritage and
their identity they help successive
generations to relive the experiences
and of their forebears and sometimes
they reveal surprises like Lincoln's
gold pocket watch it had been in Lincoln
and in the Smithsonian's collections for
many years as you know this was probably
the only really expensive thing Lincoln
ever owned he bought it before he came
to Washington and he treasured it and he
was getting tuned up by a jeweler in
1861 when the news of the Union attacked
on Fort Sumter arrived in Washington DC
the story was claimed then that the
jeweler inscribed a secret message in
the watch that Lincoln never saw and so
just a few months ago we reopened the
watch and sure enough there was the
message that this gentleman had written
supporting the abolition of
part of our history well few things are
more American than something we call the
star-spangled banner' the actual flag
that flew over Fort McHenry and inspired
Francis Scott Key to write his poem that
became our national anthem was put on
display at the Smithsonian's National
Museum of American History when it
opened the Smithsonian came into
possession of it in 1907 that flag as
you know is almost 200 years old and we
recently completed completed a ten-year
project to conserve it in a very special
way I would urge you to go back and see
it it's thrilling the point was not
ready to restore this object to its
original condition which would actually
have obliterated its history but to
clean it and stabilize this very fragile
fabric when you see it it's stunning and
at the same time preserving the marks of
two centuries in the many hands that
cared for it one of the most appealing
exhibits about this country are those at
our Air and Space Museum very popular
the spacesuits to which visitors relate
to on a very personal level to see the
size of the spacesuit and imagine
yourself in them they look at the
spacesuit for example John Glenn wore as
the very first American to enter space
in 1962 and imagine what it was like for
themselves to put it on and sit on top
of that big rocket these special
garments of course were designed to
protect our space our astronauts from
harsh conditions in outer space but
surprisingly they deteriorate very
quickly back on earth and so it's up to
the Smithsonian to preserve these
objects as long as we can indeed forever
if we can care in conservation and
technically dealing with the issues
associated with it is very important to
the Smithsonian art of course captures
another aspect of our personality as it
conveys the perspectives of our ideas
and our emotional tenor and those
usually reflect a time in which the
artwork was done the Smithsonian
American Art Museum for example is
presently featuring an exhibit called
1934 a new deal for artist Franklin
Delano Roosevelt in the middle of the
depression that we will have a heart and
funded artists to paint artwork this
artwork reminds us of a nation which had
traditional traditional values of hard
work community and optimism and this
particular painting is of the California
Golden Hills today it gives Americans
who are once again in rough economic
times an opportunity to reconnect with
our forbearers who went through similar
or maybe worse experiences and survived
and in fact remain optimistic and if you
can't make it to our museum to see these
objects we have all of them not just the
30 or 40 in the exhibition we have the
whole collection up on Flickr Commons
and you can see them all now let's say
that we've now done our 300 year time
back let's take another Smithsonian
timeline back 30,000 years ago and our
horizons broadened to the first humans
who arrived in America or in this
hemisphere the Smithsonian has been
studying the native peoples of North
Central and South America for many years
and has one of the most extensive
collections of artifacts and art from
this period in the world the research in
the collection which is the focus
particularly of the new Museum of the
American Indian touches on about 12,000
different cultures that extend back more
than 12,000 years and now some people
argue it goes even further back than
that that's another way of looking at a
time line of course art is an outgrowth
of the concept of using symbols which
humans develop we believe some time
perhaps as much as 300,000 years ago
these are examples of symbols the dawn
of a new era and the relationship of
humans and the world around them
invested a new meaning into objects that
previously were only utilitarian and it
enabled the development of languages
dispersed onehans early efforts at
cultural preservation includes the
preservation of languages because
languages embodiment of our culture
languages the way we've historically
preserved the record of our experiences
and shared values recovering voices is a
long-term effort by the Smithsonian to
capture the looks
and structure of endangered languages
before they disappear and we do it with
the rosetta stone foundation one of our
prized possessions a set of cards made
by Thomas Jefferson who has Secretary of
State wrote down short phrases of Indian
languages and translated them into
English we have the set of cards it's an
amazing thing to see them and hold them
in your hand so we are glad to share
with the Reta Rosetta long now
foundation wrote that a disc project and
particularly honored to receive the
presentation tonight in an important
effort to preserve that part of our
culture now we shifting gears again in
the Smithsonian timeline one that takes
us back about five million years when
the very earliest hominoids began to
walk around in Africa upright on two
feet the Smithsonian began studying
Paleolithic material in 1869 then is a
masked a sizable body of research and
artifacts documenting the earliest human
ancestors and next year we'll open an
exciting new exhibit on the origins of
man which incidentally will be pitched
around the notion of climate change but
his human development was very much
affected by epochs of climate change
skulls of course have always been an
important way for scientists to
understand the development of human
beings but we also pay a lot of
attention to ends and feet which changed
significantly as our ancestors moved out
of the trees to live on the ground
climbing trees and running away from a
dangerous predator or two different
things you need different appendages to
do that the big toe is no longer needed
to function like a thumb if you're
trying to run away from the bad guys and
get away from them and it's a different
kind of thing and your hand it turns out
is different as a result of our
evolution so this is important for us
then and that's actually helped
understand the difference when the new
Hobbit was found to understand it was a
different species than Homo sapiens one
more jump in the Smithsonian timeline
fifty-five million years ago when the
sceen epoch was just beginning and this
is the moment when our own earliest
primate relatives first showed up on
earth as well as the earliest ancestors
of horses sheep and pigs and that
happens to be my hand picture was taken
in Wyoming and the larger jawbone there
is that of an early horse I'm told the
interesting thing about this horse was
it was about the size of a cat and it
had something to do with climate change
in this period which I'll talk about
just a little bit later on but that was
a time when primates had a chance to
become prominent on earth we're
interested in these early developments
of primates one of those were interested
in this brush Wolski's horse last
remaining truly wild horse in the world
comes from Mongolia primarily the wild
horses on the American and Australian
Plains and islands like Chincoteague and
Cumberland are from the same genetic
line as domestic horses in contrast
fresh roscas horse has 66 genes to more
than domestic horses all the present all
ski horses alive in the world today are
descended from 14 individuals who were
snatched from the brink of total
extinction as a result their continued
survival continues to be threatened by
lack of genetic diversity and the
National Zoo which specializes in
production of habitat and in breeding
endangered species is a leader in
reintroducing fresh washed these horses
back into the wild now one more time to
understand this 55 million year ago time
period I referred to the larger context
of the emergence of the earliest mammals
we're going to go to the Bighorn Basin
located in the Wyoming badlands a place
where towns have names like Buffalo and
Grable and as I learned the local brew
that they like to mark it and is very
tasty called moose drool very good beer
the Bighorn Basin is a unique place
because it was formed as the Rocky
Mountains were simultaneously rising up
but being eroded the way the rivers are
roading Iraqis laid down thick layers of
mud and
the Bighorn Basin which subsequently
themselves were eroded into badlands so
that the rocks and fossils of millions
of years ago are quite close to the
surface now I went to Warland Wyoming
and the Bighorn Basin just a few months
ago to visit with our Smithsonian
researchers and some of their colleagues
where they've been expected trying to
excavate fossils for about 30 years our
folks are paleobotanist paleo biologists
and and they're looking not for dinosaur
bones but for plant fossils very
important and their discoveries are
making an important contribution to our
understanding of global warming we
believe Missoni enrichers and polar
regions along with others study global
warming by boring deep in the Glacial
Iseman if you're familiar with that and
removing a core in looking at one that
was laid down over a course of many
thousands of years a really good ice
cream will take you back 800,000 years
800,000 years however the past million
years which encompasses that period was
actually a time of cooling of our
planets and if you only look at that
time framing you look at what's
happening within that time frame you're
only looking at one data set about
global warming but if you look at leaf
fossils to look back 55 million years
ago you'll see a different perspective
the earth that this time fifty-five
million years ago was in a thirty
million year warm period warmer than
it's been at any time since then and at
Paleo seen epoch as it gave way to the
Eocene things heated up even more for
various reasons probably having to do
with a period of high volcanic eruption
the earth entered a period of rapid
global warming in almost ten thousand
years called the paleocene-eocene
thermal maximum which lasted over total
about 200,000 years and during that time
the average surface temperature of the
earth rose by four to eight degrees
Celsius and carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere reached levels triple that of
today remember mammals were small it was
very hot and hard for them to survive
cold-blooded animals
like snakes got bigger and so
Smithsonian folks have recently
discovered snakes as big as 45 feet in
weighing 2,500 pound though they do well
some forms of life do very well when it
gets hot
well palm-leaf fossils I'd like to
comment the type size and features of
these fossilized leaves provide a rough
thermometer if you will to the
temperatures the rough rain gauge and so
forth
what a Bighorn Basin plant fossil
indicates is that 55 million years ago
during the Paleocene Eocene maximum
therm is that the equatorial tropics
move north covering all of the United
States and this particular fossil is
something that I'm actually looking at
and it's amazing to open up a rock and
see a fossil that's been there for and
not been seen for 55 million years ago
the change was so rapid that in terms of
a geological clock it was like going to
bed in my home state of Georgia and
waking up the next morning in southern
Mexico as global warming's become an
increasing concern for our long-term
future the Smithsonian's collection of
leaf fossils in the Paleo Eocene thermal
maximum are an important research for us
resource for us to understand the future
we're going to take a further step back
55 million years is not enough and we're
gonna leave the earth for outer space to
study the development of our solar
system our galaxy and the universe
itself
if Smithsonian's first secretary was a
physicist who started the institution on
a course that has made the smithsonian
astrophysical observatory the largest
and most diverse Astrophysical
institution in the world we operate
telescopes in Hawaii
Arizona and partners in an activity in
Chile we also operate space-based
telescopes like the one shown here
telescopes are in fact mastani MERS and
astro physicist would tell us time
machines of course in the course of a
year like travels five point nine
trillion miles five point nine trillion
miles that's the light year but it's
also a measure of time for example in
this picture from the Smithsonian's
telescope in Arizona the world of the
Whirlpool Galaxy is 20 million light
years from
earth so the collision we see here
reflects how things looked 20 million
years ago as we explore the history of
the universe one of the more intriguing
questions is are there other planets out
there similar to the earth that might
have living organisms on it and this
question is the focus of the Kepler
satellite which is a project where the
Smithsonian is an important component of
it was launched in March for the next
four years Kepler will scan the Milky
Way to detect and categorize planets
that are in what we would call the
habitable zone that means they meet the
requirements for life Kepler will
continuously monitor 100,000 stars that
are similar to the Sun watching for
orbiting planets across their face and
by the way the Kepler project is
listening as well as looking because
other stars like our Sun might just be
broadcasting messages to us acoustically
Kepler indeed has already identified a
number of interesting planets like Earth
so stay tuned we'll move a little
further back in the timeline for the
Smithsonian and turned once more to the
Smithsonian collections of meteorites
the Allende meteorite this meteorite
which was discovered by Smithsonian
scientists in northern Mexico in 1969 is
the oldest known natural specimen in the
world 4.5 billion years old it contains
some of the very first matter to
condense out of the solar nebula when
our solar system formed and it also
contains tiny diamonds from the
supernova explosions of other solar
systems as well as amino acids that are
not part of our natural worth world here
on earth the wealth of significant
information it brought us has caused
some to cause this meteorite their
rosetta stone of planetary science
so we now end our journey about the
Smithsonian timeline back on on a look
on a high mountain top in Chile 8,000
feet above sea level and a climate that
is so dry
very little grows there there is no
water vapor no clouds great place for
observatories the air is crisp
and Claire devoid of moisture and
ambient light when I was there and
walked out at night it was stunning to
see I have never seen before because you
saw so much we are partners at the Las
Campanas Observatory with the Carnegie
Institution and others and we are
involved presently with the so-called
Magellan telescopes it's the only place
in the world and I don't know if you can
actually see this closely where you have
a sign that says parking reserved for
astronomers now over the course of the
next decade something called the giant
Magellan telescope will be built at Las
Campanas by an international consortium
of which we are a member this is a
powerful new telescope that will allow
us to see stars and universes ten times
more clearly than the space-based Hubble
not only will gain a clearer picture of
what happened in space millions of years
ago but as we look further out in the
universe will be looking further further
back we may be able to see events
associated with the Big Bang fourteen
billion years ago that's exciting
it's human of course nature's human
nature for us to often focus on our
differences how different we are than
others people do that on an individual
day at level in their daily lives and we
began the Smithsonian timeline with the
celebration and preservation of unique
cultures and languages but as we journey
back further in time those differences
fade away and we're reminded that in the
infinite scheme of the planet the
universe such differences are
superficial we are all from Africa we
are all made up of star dust that traces
time back to the formation our solar
system and beyond now that we've sort of
taken our quick journey we've gone
through the Smithsonian timeline back to
the origin of the universe what about
the long now the future of course our
extensive collections come from the past
to the present but as we look forward to
Smithsonian's breadth of interest and
expertise provide a unique opportunity
for collaborative long-term thinking
about across disciplines and indeed
the world I want to give you a couple of
quick examples about ecosystems we begin
in Kenya the same country where
Smithsonian anthropologists are
researching the emergence of the world's
first human beings however this time we
go to empower to a wildlife Research
Center we're in partnership with others
we've helped establish a scientific
preserve of 48,000 acres in Kenya short
very near Mount Kenya our purpose here
is to help find ways to sustain a
complex in ecosystem includes human
beings as well as a diverse and exotic
population of magnificent animals my
recent visit to the impala wildlife
preserve began with elephants and ended
with ants that's important because a
research institution the research center
correctly views all of this as an
ecosystem and all of the large and the
tiny species work together the ants live
in bulbous hollow nuts at the joints of
acacia trees which you can see up here
and they protect the acacia straight and
I can vouch for that
if you tap an acacia tree outcome the
ants don't stand too close because they
will defend their territory and they
protect the acacia tree against
parasites but they keep the acacia
stealthy that keeps the grass is healthy
and it keeps the elephants healthy it's
all connected food is important here of
course because the Impala Reserve is
surrounded by they these peoples the
Masai tribe for example in the Subaru
tribes their livestock compete with a
wildlife or food resulting in over
grazing any plan to conserve the
wildlife must consider the people that's
the challenge if all parts of the
ecosystem humans as well as wildlife can
adapt to each other the chances of
survival will be higher very important
ecosystem deteriorating rapidly
Kenya went from 9 million people to 39
million people in a very short period of
time so the competition for habitat is
substantial take you to the forest in
Panama the rainforests where the
Smithsonian's been studying tropical
forest systems there
for upwards of a hundred years not long
by long now standards but longer than
anybody else we have the longest running
continuously observed plot of land in
the barro Colorado Island in the middle
of the Panama Canal of any place in the
world our studies have made it clear
that tropical ecosystems are incredibly
dynamic and subject to climate change
small changes in the climate so we
created the Smithsonian global earth
observatories a network of forest
research plots across the world
observing consistently the same way
what's happening to the nations to the
world's rainforests and comparing those
data the goal is to keep on our hand on
the pulse of the planet by monitoring
the long term growth and survival of
65,000 species of trees in the
ecosystems that exists around them very
important to us for things like carbon
sequestration and containing the effects
of global warming philosophers and
historians of course have argued for
millennia about whether or not history
actually repeats itself but Mark Twain
probably got it right when he said
history doesn't repeat itself but it
does rhyme so the Smithsonian we're
looking for those deep underlying
rhythms that will help us prepare for
the long now of the future for example
when we look back through the history of
the planet and the major global
challenges facing us today climate
change as a common thread and a driving
force and that will also be true in our
long-term future so it's a good idea to
learn as much as we can about the
underlying long-term rhythms of global
warming and climate change predicting
the future of global warming
unfortunately is still an inexact
science and the patterns and impacts of
climate change are not well understood
global warming and climate change
affects the actions and reactions of
everything all living things the reality
is much more complex and even the most
sophisticated computer model to date as
our Smithsonian paleobiologist Scott
wing is working in Wyoming on the sites
that I described earlier says we still
have a lot to learn
and a significant portion of what we
would call the operator's manual is
carved in stone in the fossils of places
like the Bighorn Basin where we have to
learn from nature in the future the
evidence from 55 million years ago
contained in plants fossils is giving us
a better understanding of global warming
and it will help refine the models of
those who are developing them we're also
learning what we may be it might be
approaching that we've been modeling
with the wrong assumptions we've
traditionally assumed that the goal was
optimality in our model figuring out how
to sustain the best possible
configuration for the longest possible
time but the paleocene-eocene thermal
maximum implies and others that we
should be thinking about different
assumptions essentially what we need to
think about that this 10,000 years which
the carbon boiled into the atmosphere
rapidly causing dramatic global warming
actually the slower pace than we're
causing right now though because what
follow was a much longer stretch of time
when which species namely mammals settle
down and learn to live in a new
environment not all dead but some did
the key to survival was not optimality
but a depth illah depth adaptability the
challenge as our work is shown in paula
and others is to make that consistent
with our models so the challenge of
adaptability brings us full circle back
to the Smithsonian's collections and the
task of discerning
when to hold fast and when to let go
several months after 9/11 a group of
Tibetan Buddhist monks came to the
Smithsonian to make a sand mandala for
the healing of American people days
after painstakingly precise labour
yielded an intricate and beautiful sand
painting that was seven feet across one
of the largest ever made the Smithsonian
has curated the world and our curators
said we will preserve it but after it's
been on display about two weeks the
monks went through the ritual of
dismantling I meant a load with brushes
they gathered up the sand and a glass
jar and they dumped it in the Potomac
River
for them the return of the sands of the
natural environment from which it came
was a reminder of the Buddhist belief
that material life is transitory for the
Smithsonian it Illustrated once again
the eternal tension between the
ephemeral and the permanent it's not
always easy to discern which objects
should be cast aside and which ones we
should hold on to for the future those
decisions are difficult and we have
fortunately wonderful curators and
scientists to help make those decisions
we collect with a long-term purpose the
title of this talk the Smithsonian
forever comes from a quotation by a
David shaked who was a beloved curator
at the Smithsonian Museum of American
history and he passed away recently
david collected unusual objects eclectic
objects some of them were whimsical and
speak to our culture bells tools cue
sticks crayons Playboy bunny costumes
lunchboxes surfboards and much more he
collected objects from the Ground Zero
immediately after 9/11 and New Orleans
after Hurricane Katrina
he once explains his work with these
words that you see here and I think you
spoke forever one at the Smithsonian as
David noticed noted humans people are
optimists they believe in the future
they want things that have meaning for
them and they want those things to live
on beyond their lifetime it's a
recognition that the art and artifacts
in the Smithsonian's collections play an
important role in helping transfer
identity meaning and understanding from
one generation to the next to the next
we also think of all the Smithsonian's
work is taking place in the context of
forever not only because we're engaged
in the more normally important effort to
learn more about our history stretching
back through time even to the Big Bang
but also because we believe that
understanding that history will be a
useful tool in understanding our future
into the long now and beyond thank you
very much for joining me this evening
[Applause]
helene did you see this movie julia and
julie no no my wife's talking me into
that haven't been there yet we have we
have our kitchen you know the last scene
in it takes place in this smithsonian I
guess the recreation of Julia Child's
kitchen right and what is interesting
that they did in the movie is you know
the the Julie character the young
character goes in visits and photographs
herself in front of this stuff at the
Museum and then the character Meryl
Streep playing Julia Child comes into
that kitchen and plays out her final
scene in the movie and in that scene
she's been very tall she's six foot two
as a person Meryl Streep's not that tall
in that scene you see the high heels
that she's been wearing through the
whole movie that elevators are up to
beat Julia Child so there's so many
layers of illusion and present and past
intersecting in that one scene it's
remarkable the Smithsonian hadn't done
that we wouldn't have had that
opportunity to go in and out do you have
any idea how why Julia Child's kitchen
how does stuff like that come into the
museum well we do have a popular culture
section and the fact is things that we
would consider popular culture today or
maybe not totally serious may become
very serious in the future and so our
folks do collect with an intent to
collect popular culture some of that for
example will be sports sports
memorabilia are very important to
certain segments of our population and
it says something about our culture as
to what we are and what we're interested
in at a particular time and cooking is a
good thing to be interested in I suspect
in fact it goes back a long time well
here's a related question from Adrian
Cotter do you have examples of things
that the Smithsonian is not collected
you worry about missing things through
some bias of your curators that's a very
good question and something we've been
thinking about as we've been doing this
strategic planning process because just
to take an example we know that this
country is a very diverse place peoples
come from many different countries many
different parts of the world to be here
we know that by 2030 or so there will be
no majority in this case
and the Smithsonian is America's museum
is supposed to represent all of America
as well as obviously look at issues
around the world
and so if our collections tend to focus
our skew to just one part of our country
we're doing a disservice to the other
part of our country those taxes are in
fact paying for part of our operating
expenses and so we are thinking very
hard about that that we do need our
curators to think broadly about what
they collect and you know I've found for
example I tend to be eclectic about the
way I think about collections sometimes
and I ask our curators recently a group
that I'm very interested in innovation
what does an Estonian have to say about
the creative nature of America we we
tend to be an innovative country and so
we listed out a collection of things
Edison's light bulb the the compass from
Lewis and Clark's expedition the salt
vaccine and suddenly you realize all
those things tended to be European
oriented types of developments so where
were the artifacts from the American
Indian where were the artifacts from the
Asian Americans we don't have them and
so we really have to think about our
collections and how we shape them if we
want to do our job in the future we
don't want to reach the point 20 or 30
years from now and say we wish we wish
we had done that we do have Asian
American and Latin American interest
groups we do have a Museum of the
American Indian and we are going to have
a Museum of african-american history and
culture shortly but really we have to
reflect the whole panoply of the
American experience a couple of
questions on basically digital and
preservation and permanent and forever
jaime taylor asks if we own the contents
the Museum of the Smithsonian can you
explain the license that the photos and
records of holdings the Institute are
held under can I use them for my own
purposes as their a stable webpage for
each item in the collection that would
be kind of like the Encyclopedia of life
you know there'll be a page for each
thing one point what do you got 137
billion items we have 137 million
objects a lot of those are insects and
things that you don't necessarily want
to rush out and look at but we have lots
of them
we are in the process of thinking
through a whole strategy for digitizing
our collection because even those things
that the average average person may want
to see our entire collection of tix
a lot of them but teachers and
scientists would and anybody interested
in infectious diseases from ticks would
and so we're trying to think through how
you digitize these collections in a way
that makes it one of our problems we
have is most of our objects are not
two-dimensional then we have 13 million
photographs but most of our objects are
three-dimensional so how do you show
three dimensionality in an image how
many images do you need to see the full
three-dimensional aspect of these things
and so we don't scan I got a question
right here about it and so we're working
on oh these are all live issues if you
want to share some information with us
we'd love to hear about it but we are
moving we're working hard in it we had a
group in clay about Anderson Chris
Anderson's here and Clay Shirky was
there and so forth we talked about what
how the Smithsonian should engage the
web in terms of communicating with
people we know we're behind the times on
that but we're going to work hard on
that the images that we have these are
all publicly available images you can
use the images if they're on our web
site a lot of our images insted in their
own Flickr so those are obviously
available to anybody a question from Rob
Smith you've been talking about the
future of Education that since the
future of science which area of science
deserves the most attention do you think
but is receiving the least and what can
you guys do about that well I think the
interesting question there is I think
we're all concerned that we have
generations of young people going
through our K through 12 public school
system particularly that don't have
access to the kind of science education
perhaps that we had and that they need
in a new environment and a new
competitive world that we're going to
have to exist in in the next couple of
decades and the question is how do we do
that today a lot of our science teachers
they're wonderful folks and they're
doing everything they can but they are
required for example to prepare students
for national tests and it takes away
from their ability to do things in some
cases they don't have the recessed
resources I used to have to do lab
exercises we think the Smith's own
can help and we're working with
different school entities groups for
them to tell us what we can do that will
help them we're not going to offer
science courses per se that's already
out there what we will do is be able to
fill in gaps through our collections and
through our curators while you won't see
many of our collections you won't meet
many of our curators either we'd like to
change that these are brilliant
wonderful people and they would make
great teachers great people to help
science teachers get their subjects
across but the Encyclopedia of life is a
good example where we will put all 1.8
million species on a webpage we think
it's 1.8 million at this time we suspect
they're more but we're losing some as we
discover them but what we also find is
that we can create a website that's a
trusted website science teachers will be
willing to share their lesson plans with
science teachers and other places so we
want to become a place where we can help
trans and transition knowledge from one
place to the other to our school
teachers who are are creative and want
to work with each other we can become a
national resource in that regard a
couple of questions one from Loreen
Palmer one from susan house the
smithsonian dealing with the issue of
countries and cultures wanting to
repatriate objects in the collections
okay well obviously this is something
that's very much on everyone's mind
starting today our starting cook you
know more recently you don't take
objects from a country period you don't
remove anything you don't remove fossils
you don't remove works of art you don't
move any kind of artifact from a country
anymore unless somebody gives you
permission to do that and there are
reasons to do it many times we will make
an agreement with the country that will
take an object for 20 years and then
we'll return it at that point in time
now there's a term called repatriation
and I'm not the true expert on this
behind you I'm a civil engineer by trade
but repatriation is something that's
done within the United States it regards
remains from Native Americans that we
have possession of that we repatriate
and we are steadily doing that as those
requests are made outside of the United
States we return objects we don't
repatriate because that's not the same
phrase when when it's requested and when
it makes sense to do that but we have
returned
objects including human remains as well
as works of art the countries when they
made the request but this is an
interesting era that we live in going
forward and this can have in a way a
kind of a stifling effect on scholarship
if you don't construct a new way for
people to share information because of
every country keeps everything it owns
and doesn't share it in some way then we
all lose so the question is we have to
create a new way of sharing information
if in fact every country keeps the
objects that they believe belong to them
and that's rightfully theirs there's an
interesting one from Robin Sloane how do
national museums generally fare in times
of political upheaval Iraq comes to mind
if or when the US government goes
through a dramatic transition what does
the Smithsonian do to hang in there and
you know this is something you plan for
other words that gonna be ad hoc well
let me just address the Iraq situation
where obviously treasures were lost or
broken or destroyed some of which have
come back but not completely and we've
had we've loaned experts to the iraqi
museums to help them in the work they're
doing to secure those artifacts and to
repair the artifact one of the
challenges when you collect is you have
to if you're collecting forever is you
have to maintain objects you have to
have experts in different materials to
maintain those object spacesuits special
material fabric special material metal
special material and so forth and so we
have experts at the Smithsonian that
other museums don't have and we share
that expertise to help others in terms
of protecting the objects that they have
the Smithsonian itself is supported by
the federal government about 65% of our
budget comes from federal appropriations
the rest we raise ourselves through
philanthropy through stores through
sales so if you're at the Smithsonian
didn't hurt to buy a little something
that helps our bottom line we are trying
like many museums to become what I say
is more self-reliant that may mean we
will charge for services in the future
that we haven't charged for in the past
simply because we don't have the
resources to do the thing that we have
to do in the
future it's just you know we have these
collections we have to maintain the
collections we don't want to lose them
and so you have to find a way through
these difficult time we're very grateful
for the support we've gotten from the
federal government but it's still a
challenge for us
so part of what libraries and museums
often do when times are tight is you do
a little DX sessioning and sort of
goodness or the question here from Adam
what's the process of item is being
removed from the Smithsonian collection
okay there are these words that are used
you know we don't say getting rid of
stuff is the exceptional right work so
we acquire which is called sessioning
and then we the accession and so and
there's a protocol that's a well
established protocol in the museum
community about accession and about the
accession we're very careful today about
what we accession we don't want to
acquire things that are duplicates of
things we already have that would be
silly if a fellow or the other thing is
that as most people are learning is you
collaborations a positive thing so if
the Field Museum in Chicago has an a
beautiful collection of a certain type
of artifact we don't need to have it we
can work with the field to borrow from
them they can borrow from us at any
given time five million of our artifacts
that the Smithsonian our collections are
on loan to other museum and so museums
are now getting smarter about it
nobody's trying to do it all anymore
which is a one of the smart ways of
trying to avoid this attractive piece
then that that you basically have some
knowledge network knowledge of what's in
all the museums in the world and they
have the same of you
yes that's pretty interesting us look
into that I'm sure you can it's all
public information so I'm sure you can
but the I don't know how that would all
be to the world that sort of exists in
some Network done online ish fashion or
we're asking guys not that type of an
expert but what I do know is that
museums themselves are working together
in collaboration to share information
about what's in their collections and as
we digitize more of this information we
know more about what is in our
collections and what
other people's collections because it
doesn't make any sense for us to
duplicate now you know in the university
world because he found that museum has
something maybe it's a better one or an
older one or some like that what do you
do with the thing that you now have this
redundant week in the accession them and
we do things that are redundant yeah if
I don't my version of the story one of
the things I wanted to do when I came to
the Smithsonian was understand what they
call an installation speech that's when
you get inaugurated sounds like being
installed like a mechanical implants but
it was an installation so I read all the
installation speeches of the twelve
eleven secretaries before me and what I
noticed was that the number of artifacts
every one of them mentioned the number
of artifacts and it was going up it was
going up it was going up until about
1996 and it started going down and so I
asked myself the question why was that
true we started the accession and so we
had a peak of 144 meagan objects we're
now down to 137 million weirdy accession
annow at the same time we're collecting
now admittedly in interest of full
disclosure we acquired a huge stamp
collection at one point in time and so
about five or six million of those
things we dig session were stamps well
we still have a great stamp collection
just we don't duplicate anymore but we
do sell them to private collectors or
other museums or what happens you can if
we can and it depends on the way in
which we acquired the object sometimes a
donor will say you can never sell it and
that's the way it is sometimes donors
say and under certain circumstances you
can sell you know in contemporary art
that's much more common than it is in
other foreign because contemporary art
changes so much and if it turns out that
we you know we may have inherited a
collection from a donor who wants to
will it to us and within that collection
you've got you know 16 pieces by the
same artist it may not be necessary to
have 16 pieces it's silly for us to take
works of art into a collection and keep
them in our you know in storage these
things should be out and it must better
for us to give them out loan them and or
make sure they're available to somebody
else so you looked at these previous
installation speeches
and then probably noticed how long those
various secretaries lasted what's there
you know is there any pattern there of
what's the the typical of the time in
office for a secretary of Smithsonian
it varies obviously so sexually
parallels university presidents
lifespans for yeah university presidents
you're staying around 2025 years and
then it got all the way down to about
four years it's been getting up it's up
to about seven now Smithsonian sort of
like that it's it went in the early days
the folks stayed around for about twenty
twenty-five years and more recently it's
been somewhere between five and ten how
do you explain that well if you look
back they're very since under reasons
for it the last gentleman had a
particular problem no actually there's
some giggling by people you know I'd
love to hear how you describe the
problems well they were they were
described fairly explicitly to me in the
sense that don't do these again which
words well you know there was a the the
problems we do that that people wanted
him gone for I think particularly some
of the expenditures that were made in
the way those expenditures were made
were problems and so the objective was
in my case for example we we didn't want
a house that belong to Smithsonian we
didn't want any of the couch moments
that came with that so we have our town
house I walk to work it's a much more
logical way to do business then than the
old way fair enough there's a lot less
perks amused Bob Coppock I should say
instead oh the perk is being secretary
because I get to meet these incredibly
interesting people and see these amazing
collections and understand the stories
behind all this collection your brains
out raising money to sell them all but I
love to do Bob Coppock has an
interesting long-term question he says
forever is a very long time what is your
real time horizon
well and we had that discussion with a
long now board because you know what is
the time that you can expect the
Smithsonian to how long will it exist
and then the question comes back with
what well we're part of this country how
long will this country exist and its
existed so far about 300 years I think
we would all like to think we might be
here 300 years from now
500 years I like to think a thousand
years now tell people at the Smithsonian
who worked there that what we want to
make sure is that if we are still here a
thousand years from now we want people
to look back and say those guys did a
pretty good job we don't want to look
back and say what were those people
thinking about and you know back in that
time so I think we have to presume that
it's a long time and we have to presume
we'll be lucky that that will be true as
our country and as this great
institution will be some institutions
last that long now there was a couple
questions buried in here of the National
Park System says it serves future
generations and indeed does it very well
do you guys intersect with the National
Park System at all or are you different
worlds not too much but we intersect
quite immediately in Washington because
we have museums along this thing called
the National Mall and the National Mall
doesn't belong to us that belongs to the
park service so the Park Service
operates the National Mall and all the
activities that go on in the National
Mall National Mall you know extends all
the way down to the Tidal Basin and the
Jefferson Memorial and so forth and we
own everything up to the curb I'm told
and so we interact with them we're
working with them right now because as a
group trying to restore the health of
the National Mall and we want to work
with them it's our front yard
what do you mean the health the health
of the National Mall the mall itself if
it's sick it's not as it doesn't look as
nice as it used to it's pretty well beat
up it is a it's like Smithsonian museums
in a way in that they're used heavily
that's a good thing the American people
use them all people use it for football
games and rugby games and softball games
as well as formal events and
inaugurations
seven hundred and forty thousand people
walk through our Museum at the time of
the inauguration and so it is heavily
used it for not to bore you with it but
it used to be it that that used to be a
river called a Tiber River and it's a
filled in area of a lot of sediment that
really is not the world's best sediment
for growing grass the grass is a very
old kind of grass we need to replant it
so we're working with them to help them
hopefully get a more durable kind of
grass that will continue to support the
level of activity at have well since you
know people talk about the Smithsonian's
the nation's attic and I suppose in a
way the mall is the nation's front yard
and gets appropriate you know I don't
use the word nation data why
well the and attic you know I grew up in
the deep south and so attics were
important we didn't have basements down
there didn't need them and but we had
attics and you think of an attic in at
least inside you always stuck your head
up in the attic
it was hot you know you could see a
little bit of light you saw dust motes
floating around and there were things up
there that people had abandoned probably
for good reason you're never going to
use them the Smithsonian is a place
that's intellectually active that takes
care of things when it has them in its
possession we try to guard them against
deterioration forever and ever we try to
display them we try to think of
intellectual ways to stimulate the
American people and all the visitors
from other countries to think about life
and its relationships in different ways
so it I see it as a far distant thing
from an attic it is a intellectually
vibrant place now museums have back
rooms and basements and attics and stuff
where the stuff that's not a display is
and I've done research and behind the
scenes that's been so you know there's
amazing stuff back there is Peter
Schwartz came back from traveling with
you to some of the back rooms in the
Smithsonian's it was amazing stuff is
there a way for other for that to be
more accessible somehow not just
digitally but to you know I don't know
do tours or something like that because
it is such fun to see the stuff on a
shelf next to you know a bunch of other
things like it but they're sort of
different and the kind of things you
just can't
out in front yeah when Chris and his
folks came back that was one of the
things we did was to give folks that
tour and one of the participants said
something very interesting he said I
grew up in Washington I've been to the
Smithsonian 40 times I even when I come
back from California I go and he said
that's the first time I've ever really
understood this pyth Sounion because I
got to do the behind-the-scenes tour so
that was a bit of a revelation to me
thinking how can we use digital
processes to allow people to connect to
that experience the problem is we can't
conduct sort of guided tours of these
facilities they just aren't set up to do
that there's no room you can take maybe
ten people down at a time but you
couldn't functionally get there because
we have seven million people pouring
into Natural History as an example and
the objects are sort of out there you
know and so you aren't supposed to touch
these objects they're preserved and so
forth and so that's the difficulty we do
have collection centers two of them in
Maryland two giant collection centers
where we have many of these things again
they're protected there it is a
marvelous experience to go there it's
just difficult to take people back to
these areas and because they just aren't
set up to do it but digitally we should
be able to do these things and digitally
and through the web we can bring our
curators out and they can walk people
through virtually through these
collections I can deal with contained
walkways and if you were Dutch you'd be
figuring out a way to charge people that
you know walk by the folks that are
wrapping the flowers and doing all that
stuff and you know the in the lumber
camps where they have a walkway that
goes over I think everybody gets to
watch everything no isolated walkways we
have a group and that's one of the items
on their list is there a way to do this
some areas we probably can do it and we
should because it's thrilling to be able
to see these things Kevin Kelly has
questioned in several versions of the
past several decades the center of
American culture has been the computer
and digital stuff how's the Smithsonian
collecting preserving presenting
intangible digital masterpieces well and
I suppose just you know the kind of
random stuff I mean some of these
questions came in by Twitter how you're
preserving Twitter
that's the popular culture thing okay
that's a very interesting question and
it was asked recently by Vint Cerf who
did invent the Internet what we're doing
about it the answer is probably not
enough as one of those someone asked the
question earlier about her collections
and are we looking at them in a broad
way to make sure we're preserving all
aspects that is one of those issues now
we do have a group called the Folklife
group which I find fascinating that
collects music and collects spoken
records and so we have a tremendous
number of recordings and we make a
little money on those because you can
get them on iTunes from all they are in
blue or work that was done way back in
the 30s 20s and tens and so forth so
that kind of information we have
maintained digitally we're able to do
that digitally and we're keeping and we
have more and more photographs and
things like that from the modern era but
it's a very interesting question
somebody asked for the question recently
about all the digital photographs that
are taken I don't know which how you
choose which digital photographs are the
best but this is a growing issue and
then the next question is if you
digitize something today will you have a
device around 15 years from now that
will read what you digitize today and so
there all kinds of interesting questions
are out there for us is that something
the Smithsonian is taking on or sort of
waiting for a solution to appear from
somewhere and they will adopt it I think
we're waiting for somebody to tell us a
little more about that but it is a major
issue for us as we move down the road of
digitizing our collections is will we
still be able to see them 15 years from
now after we digitize them do you
interact with the National Archive very
much we do very closely work with them
as well as Library of Congress the
Library of Congress and archives are
probably ahead of us in doing some of
their digital collections for them it's
this is gonna be sooner rather than
later a huge problem I think and I I
don't know who the hell is ahead in this
area I don't think there is anyone
really I mean you know on it if anybody
knows let me know Stanford
yeah Mike Keller and in the Stanford
working with the Google books and things
like that they're not the case it's the
web is becoming a Smithsonian of the sky
and some respect and as long as it
doesn't perish into a black hole of dead
links or something you know that's kind
of the hope that that is self is
self-sustaining and then that raises the
question of what does Smithsonian do
with the living web I mean yeah well
what events worth telling you to do but
I mean one of the things we often tend
to think too much about digitizing and
putting things out in sort of a passive
way to me the real value is going to be
in the social networking side of the web
making people tell us what they think
letting them get into our collection
we're already learning things about our
collections that we don't know that
other people know if somebody may have a
personal connection to an object we have
in our collections that we may have put
our experts on but they couldn't see it
and so having the web as a tool to allow
people to share their intelligence with
us the swarm in fact is I think a very
powerful concept that's a good answer it
occurs to me that you're a hundred and
thirty seven billion thing that's made
out of atoms that's actually somewhat
unique and that you're in this
interesting relationship that seems to
be going on perpetually between things
and and virtuality basically and you've
got close to a monopoly on things so you
don't want a completely punt on digital
and virtual and cloud and all that stuff
but on the other hand you can sort of
say you know go ahead and be as
ephemeral and amazing and fast-moving as
you want we got the stuff well there's
another side of this too and don't
forget the scientific side of the
collection for example insects today the
world is absolutely totally connected
today at any given time the flowers you
put on your table as your flower display
may have come yesterday from Kenya and
when they came from Kenya and they came
into this country they carried insects
with them and the question is were those
insects native to this country are they
native are they going to be invasive
species that's a big issue and so
having a digital database and having
collections so that when these objects
arrive in the United States and you have
only a small amount of time to say yes
or no you can't keep cut flowers sitting
there for you know three days while
you're making up your mind having the
digital database quickly there and it's
not there yet but we're getting there
with the Department of Agriculture to
help people who are making those
decisions quickly make that decision so
that becomes a utilitarian type of tool
but you have to digitize it in order to
be able to get the information back
quickly because of the connectivity in
the world day well here's a case of that
and when you're doing your criminal
investigation of those geese that
flavorant Lee flew into the engines of
the airplane over New York how did you
guys find out that they were migratory
what's the actual process of doing that
okay okay and I'm gonna tell you what
our folks told me okay but the first was
the feathers and you know I've got going
down to that we have a feather
identification lab and the scientist who
runs its name aptly named Carla dove and
Carla is a very very brilliant scientist
and she has a group of people who work
with her there she they received 4,500
bird strike cases a year that are sent
to them for identification of planes or
trucks of planes whatever strikes a play
some of those related to the military
but many of them related to civilian
airports it's important for airports to
know do we have birds who are you know
using our place as an environment to
grow their young and sadly enough you
got to shoo them off because you don't
want them around airplane I don't want
to really make you nervous about flying
but the fact is 500 strikes why should
we worry that's it yeah
so if and you know you go down to this
lab and they show you they pull out the
stuff from the Hudson River miracle
plane and it's feathers yeah there were
some feathers left over from the impact
and there was also I would personally
call it non scientifically goo on some
inion engine parts and it was some
combination to the feathers they can
particularly the bottom part of feathers
I'm told by our feather experts are very
important to identifying bird species
then they line them up against all our
collections
very important and then they do DNA
studies and isotope studies and they can
actually see what the birds have been
eating and it's from that bit of
information you determined that these
birds were not eating Coney Island hot
dogs they had in fact been feeding on
certain kind of food that are found and
found in a certain place in Canada
before they migrates these were
migratory geese they had migrated to New
York City as a place of warmth in the
winter and the presumption is that at
that particular time of day it was about
the time when geese get up and go look
for food and these birds even though
they were in New York City they were
there temporarily and they had lifted
off as a flock to go look for food
locally they were about 2,900 feet when
they hit the plane and you can get into
all the details about how plane engines
are designed for bird impact they are
designed for certain sizes of birds this
we had three of them and they're all
about eight pounders and they all hit
the engines about the same time and
turned out couldn't take it and that's
now going back to the Boeing and Airbus
they're all redesigning their engines as
a result of that goose catchers in front
or what I mean one wonders how do you
design for an eight pound bird that's
strike three
now one of the things I encountered then
we're winding up here but the trends of
science the Encyclopedia of life and
barcoding of life are quite different
than the way taxonomy used to be done
taxonomy used to be done by specialists
you have some in the Smithsonian who
would you know find a certain twig of
the Tree of Life and then own it and if
you found particularly enos of beetle
you thought you had a new species into
said your beetle to that bloke wherever
he or she was and months later if you
were lucky word would come back sorry
it's been discovered years ago you
wasted your time and there was it was a
slow tight anal process right I'm a
biologist so I do
like it but it was weird and then Along
Came GenBank and the sharing of
half-baked data and instead of getting
power for the questioning stuff I
started getting power in science from
hearing stuff even sharing stuff that
wasn't really ready for primetime
because it would become ready for
primetime out there right the web is
Smithsonian in the thick of that or
trailing along behind or what we're very
actively involved in the barcode a life
project and so everybody understands
that this is the idea is to try to find
a snippet of your genetic material they
can use to identify a particular species
and as Stewart said in the past when you
had a species and for example and
potentially invasive species to find out
if this was a new species or not it took
months and the idea is to have this DNA
information and digitized information so
that when you have a species that you're
believe may be invasive or new that you
can quickly in a matter of minutes
literally if you get on the database
identify new species and this is very
important because we're losing species
all the time and we're discovering new
species and when I said that there were
1.8 million anticipated pages of the
Encyclopedia of life webpages we have no
idea if that's the real number I'm told
by some of our entomologist
it could be 30 million species on earth
we just don't know about it 100 million
yeah that's not counting the microbes
huge number but having a way to quickly
identify a species is very important to
know if you have a new species and to be
able to do it quickly for any number of
scientific as well as practical reasons
to understand that so here's the
impression I get your stuff would drive
the Smithsonian toward being sort of
stodgy and protective if in you know we
got the stuff leave us alone
and yet your science is always
scrambling out there toward multiplicity
of Horizons using the multiplicity of
new instrumentalities and mechanisms and
shared misses and all the rest of that
to keep up with lead science by virtue
of all that happening in one institution
you can't get stodgy mmm well I would
just that's true to a certain point but
it's very easy for an institution like
the Smithsonian because we are so
comprehensive in many ways so diverse is
to stay within our own orbit and it's
important for us not to do that we can't
afford to do everything is impossible
for us to do it we know that other
institutions know that we don't have all
the spark people other institutions
house for people other people have
collections we don't have as I mentioned
and we discussed earlier this business
about restoration of artworks and
fossils around the world is that you're
going to have to share these collections
in the future you can't have them you're
going to have to share them in the
future
and so collaboration and sharing of
information will be far more important
in the future than it's been in the past
we're starting to sign an MoU with
universities we already worked with a
lot of universities with Stanford
memorandums of understanding with
universities where we can see there they
can do things that can complement what
we can do and vice versa
we the Smithsonian is a little bit of an
unusual outfit these collections are the
kinds of things universities have a hard
time maintaining today many universities
are divesting themselves of collections
because of financial pressures and
remember it's not just holding the
objects you've got to preserve them just
Park downriver of those guys and collect
the stuff as it comes pouring out of the
University and but part of our job will
be all of these objects really should be
available to any other scientist who
wants use they are really today but
there will be more so in the future
digitally will help but we are visiting
scientists all over the world all the
time and if you take an example of what
we do down at barro Colorado Island we
have upwards of a thousand visiting
scientists and students a year who take
advantage of the work we've done we're
sort of like a national lab in that way
we've created this spot where we have
the baselines we have a date of the
observations over a hundred years and
scientists from all over the world
students in fact people can visit barro
Colorado Island for a mall price and see
this remarkable place and see the work
that's going on there and it's being
technology you know technologically
driven today with little micro collars
they put on animals and so forth and
cameras that we can see things we've
never been able to see before it's
really an eye-opener when you see it but
sharing with other scientists with other
vigils is important and will become more
important that sounds like the future
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you